こんにちは
浜口雅紀です
先ほどご説明にもあった通り8 mh って
言われてるんですけど
飯っていうのは誰だイニシャルを
組み合わせたものなので気にしなくて
大丈夫です
8僕は高校3年生で今マジックをつくっ
たりやったりして sns に投稿したり
あてぃなのでちょっといろいろ演じてみ
たりいろいろしていますまずは僕が
なかなかと説明するよりも実際に見て
いただいた方がよくわかると思うので
こちらの
キラキラしたおり瓶をよく見てください
これは一瞬で折り鶴に変化してしまいます
今観ていただいて分かったと思うんです
けど僕のマジック非常に短いです
基本的に一瞬で終わりますただと一瞬で
終わらないマジックもあるんですけど僕の
マジックは基本的にその短い
マジックをたくさん
やっていくスタイルでやっています
ん
そしてへと今日はいくつかマジックを持っ
てきたんですが
おそらくそんなに時間がかからないで
終わると思うので
ぜひ
集中して見ていただければと思います
よろしくお願いします
それではまず1つめのマジックからやって
いきたいと思うんですが
こちらの青いカードを使います
このマジックはですね僕が
このマジックは僕があの
マジックを始めた頃ですね今高校3年生な
んですけど中学校1年生の時にマジックを
本格的に始めて初めてトランプを買って出
始めたトランプを買った時の色が青色なん
ですね
で初めて作ったマジックを今からお見せし
たいと思います
こんな感じで
編となんの変哲もないって言うと怪しい
ですけど
青いカードがあります
このカードがよく向けてください
手をかざすと
一瞬で赤色にすべての色が変わってしまい
ます
はじまりはこんなマジックからでした
えっとこのマジックの何が特徴的かという
とあまり隠さないということです
普通のマジックだとこうやって手で
覆い隠してしまうことが多いんですけど僕
のマジックてお手の隙間を空けたりだとか
あと何も隠さないとかそういった
そのいわゆるビジュアルマジックと言われ
ているあの視覚的なマジックを
どう僕はとても大好きなのでができれば
その cg とか魔法みたいと言われる
ようなマジックを目標に作っています
それでは次のマジックに入っていきます
こんな感じであのテンポ良く言っていき
ますので
宜しくお願いします
次のマジックはですね
普通の一般的にジャンルとしてはあるん
ですけど
消えるっていうのショップです
経過他にも色んな種類がありますこちらの
赤いカードをよく見てください
このカードがしたから少しずつ
聞いてしまいます
こんな感じで今の一瞬ではないんですけど
すごく早く終わりましたね
これはあの
8をゆっくり消えるところをできるだけ
見えるように改良した結果になります
そんな感じで僕のマジックあのいろいろ
あの進化してるって自分で言うとアレです
けど
進化してるつもりでおりますはいそれでは
次のマジックです次のマジックはですね
あの
考えたのがつい最近ですえっとおととい
くらいです
あのうち半数とかいろいろなこととして
できるかできないかっていうラインになっ
て自分で考えたマジックになりますこう
いうカードを使います破れています
ちょっと変わってますよね
でこの敗れたんカードを見るといろんな人
が思うと思うんですけど復活草と思うん
ですね
よく見てくださいこれが一瞬で
カードが復活してしまいます
カードマジックというのはいろんな
ジャンルがあってその
例えば色が変わるとか
ものが消えるとかものが出現するとかもの
が貫通するとかそういったものがあるん
ですけど
今回はカードを復活させてみました
ということで早いですが僕のシクはこんな
感じで終わりたいと思いますありがとう
ございます